[Music]
what was your first computer science
textbook
i feel like it was called like java by
construction
was my first textbook it was like an
introduction to programming in java
which i took in a freshman coding class
in princeton
my mom gave me a textbook when i was
about eight years old
on introduction to python and she
started reading it to me while i was in
class and that was a huge moment for me
i got a textbook on matlab programming i
think
and i don't know if i ever cracked the
spine of it once
clrs textbook the algorithms textbook
that they use in the algorithms class
here at mit
it's a it's definitely like a
mammoth of a textbook but i feel like
it's sort of a rite of passage
i wasn't you know i wasn't a huge fan of
textbooks i mostly read for i read
the course notes that were posted in a
lot of quests but there's a uh there's
an introduction to algorithms textbook i
used i think it's by
uh by one of the kleinbergs
and maybe avatardos as well um and
and that was that was a great textbook i
love that textbook and uh and it's
really fun because each pro
each problem is sort of structured as
like a little puzzle that you have to
solve
so that was my first textbook that i
enjoyed
you know i don't think i've ever used a
computer science textbook
when i really think through all of my
computer science classes maybe they
assigned a textbook if i didn't get it
most of the time the problem sets were
available online the lectures were all
available online
and most of what you learn is from
googling all the different questions you
might have and other people tell you
from
maybe i guess textbook wise wikipedia
wikipedia is my favorite computer
science textbook
[Music]
you